emergency number one friend of ours is
leading in our house who was president
investigators forensics experts True
Crime jocks nobody has seen anything
like this one Robert Wan decided to
spend the night with three friends we
have their story that an intruder broke
in and Robert was stabbed three times
one two three bang the story just took
off from there the detectives walked
into a surreal scene the
gravity is stunning there were NATO
marks on his neck
something was very off you don't take
three to the chest play there and die
that's what makes this story so
maddening this case has more questions
than it has answers
no evidence of struggle there was almost
no blood on the scene where is the
missing blood when I die the first
question I'm gonna ask God who killed
Robert Wong
[Music]